we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors steadymd lets you maintain a
meaningful long-lasting relationship
with a primary care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit
steadymd.com pacman to get started
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman welcome to the show uh the
current administration is likely to
behave outrageously all the way to the
end
of the end which is going to be uh
wednesday
january 20th and in the meantime we're
expecting
a lot of action in different ways
yesterday house democrats did introduce
articles of impeachment against donald
trump this is the second
impeachment against donald trump and
trump could be very quickly heading to
being the only president to be impeached
two times this article of impeachment
filed yesterday
is for inciting the mob that attacked
the capital
last week and uh we now have
a question mark as to what will the next
24 to 36 hours look like and i'll talk
about that with you
in a moment nancy pelosi and
the rest of her caucus of the
constituency of democrats in the house
are also simultaneously working the 25th
amendment angle which again
i don't believe is actually going to go
anywhere but there
they want vice president mike pence
along with donald trump's cabinet to
intervene and simply remove donald trump
now as i've said before
removal of trump via the 25th amendment
was warranted
years ago and it continues to be
impeachment of donald trump again
is warranted and it is the right thing
to do
even though neither is likely to remove
trump even a minute short of when his
term will end
at noon eastern time next wednesday but
these
are responsibilities that our lawmakers
have not political calculations to be
made and so i've i have said that
they should indeed go forward and the
schedule as we now understand it
and because things are moving so quickly
by the time you listen to this there may
have been some modification
the house is uh likely to vote
tonight formally calling on vice
president pence to strip trump of the
presidency
via the 25th amendment um so the process
so far has been
articles of impeachment introduced
yesterday we hear from nancy pelosi
that the articles of impeachment will be
voted on potentially tomorrow at 9 00
a.m
if pence does not act to remove donald
trump via the 25th which of course
requires the cabinet as well
uh and if indeed that doesn't happen
then
and only then would there be an
impeachment vote
and so this is the new york times is
describing this as a standoff between
two branches of government
house democrats are pressuring mike
pence to intervene
and are so that that's between the house
uh uh and and the executive and then at
the same time
you are potentially going to see a
standoff between democrats and
republicans
not so much within the house where the
democrats appear to
very clearly have the votes to impeach
trump a second time
but with regard to what's going to
happen in the senate and it has already
been discussed that
there is of course not time to conduct a
senate impeachment trial
between now or what is more likely going
to be tomorrow the impeachment vote and
the end of donald trump's presidency
that would be just one week
but that is not a problem legally
speaking a president can be impeached
after they they leave office they can be
convicted on impeachment after they
leave office
but if you start that in two weeks or in
three weeks what do you do to the first
hundred days of joe biden
when we are um desperately needing
to accelerate vaccine distribution we
are in the middle of a
disastrous handling of a global hundred
year pandemic and joe biden
presumably plans to do quite a bit in
his first hundred days so the idea has
already been floated of
you vote to impeach during trump's term
and then you hold those articles of
impeachment delaying the senate trial
for a period of several months we don't
we just don't know
at this point what's going to happen now
at the same time
you might recall that donald trump and
mike pence
hadn't met since the riotous
insurrection on wednesday
and reportedly hadn't even spoken we've
now learned thanks to new york times
reporting that trump met with pence
yesterday for the first time since he
publicly denounced mike pence
on twitter as the riotous insurrection
was happening trump taking to twitter
and saying pence didn't
he didn't do it he just didn't do the
right thing and
uh the meeting was reportedly more than
an hour long
and um it it you know there are varying
reports from what happened but it's
being described as
a fraught peace summit where
the conversation is described as good
but it's unclear whether pence said
listen the pressure for me to use the
25th is growing
and you should do this that or the other
thing to prevent me from having to do it
although every indication we've received
so far uh
is that it is very unlikely that mike
pence is going to
act in that way so i for me
the real issue here is not one of
political calculation
and it is not one of uh legacy for
people like pence or other republicans
i've already said
all of these republicans that in the
last 14 days
16 days of trump's presidency have come
out and said this is impeachable or he
should resign or he should be removed or
this is now over the line
these are not people who deserve really
any praise from us
for what they are doing it doesn't take
courage
when trump is at his weakest and when
much of the republican party but
certainly much of the country has turned
against him and he's leaving anyway
it doesn't take courage at that point to
come out and say yeah he should go
it would have taken courage maybe uh to
do it before
when they actually would have been at
electoral risk i'm talking about
republican senators and members of
congress and others
and at this point in time it's merely a
calculation about self-preservation
there are republicans who have
calculated
and maybe they are right that at this
point distancing from trump
uh 14 days before he's gone rather than
a day after he's gone
is better for them and that's really
what this is about
even people like lindsey graham we
talked about oh lindsey graham on
january 6th or i guess it was really
january 7th very early january 7th in
the morning
he he gave this speech saying we biden's
the president and we must and we it's
we can't hold this up and some people
said wow that was a great speech by
lindsey graham lindsey graham is one of
the slipperiest
brown nosers of trump and within hours
of that as we covered yesterday lindsey
graham was on fox news
uh begging for mercy for trump and
saying listen trump did the right thing
he lowered the temperature and he made a
you know a useful productive statement
saying
joe biden well he actually didn't say
joe biden there will be a transition and
i'm committed to it
even the people that seem to be uh sort
of talking sense
are really trying to play both sides and
there are there are a few exceptions i
mean listen
mitt romney at least he stopped playing
both sides years ago
he met with trump early during the
transition
it looked at the 2016 transition mind
you
it looked like maybe romney was being
considered for secretary of state
and he went and had frog's legs or
turtle soup or whatever with trump
and then he wasn't considered and
earlier romney
said what was on his mind i disagree
with romney and that i think his
condemnation should have been much
stronger
i disagree with romney and that romney's
still a religious republican and
i'm not but at least my belief is romney
was telling us what he really felt for
years
whereas with lindsay it's flip-flopping
constantly and playing both sides so
impeachment vote tomorrow at 9am the
most likely scenario and we'll let you
know what happens
we have to talk about something really
important today and the reason that this
is so important
is that we can't solve problems unless
we understand them
and over the last few days as different
folks have weighed in
on the violent trumpest insurrection
that took place last week
i've seen more and more commentaries
that are missing the boat when it comes
to the immediate and proximate causes
of the insurrection and of the coup
attempt and specifically i'm talking
about
claims that ultimately what happened
last week
comes down to merely economic unfairness
and inequality and anger by the
so-called working class and
even lots of people that i greatly
respect have weighed in on this
issue and i believe they are wrong i'll
give you an example
with total peace and love my former
economics professor from the university
of massachusetts
economist richard wolff tweeted quote
what was seen in the capitol building of
washington on january
6 was another manifestation of angry
working class people this will only
continue
unless basic changes happen in this
country we need to do something
about the inequality of this society i
love richard wolff he's been a guest on
this show a dozen times i was recently
on his show
this is the worst take i've ever seen
from richard wolff who typically has
really great takes uh to some degree
this idea is a version of class
reductionism
class reductionism is the idea that in
the end
all oppressions strife violence unrest
it all comes down merely to class
struggle
and uh racial struggle is really class
struggle
and nationalistic struggle is really
class struggle etc it's a gender
struggle is really class struggle
and that if we reduce inequality it's
going to solve all of these different
problems
and i think we have to be very careful
because
nobody's claiming that economics and
class struggle
uh are are not important in in
just about everything that we see in our
political system
and even those claiming that it played a
role last week
are right but in this particular case
the class struggle aspect of this absent
a more detailed and comprehensive
analysis falls
woefully short in explaining what
happened last week remember
shortly after donald trump was elected
there was a whole bunch of talk about
this was about economic anxiety economic
anxiety motivated people to give donald
trump a shot because he spoke
to those economic anxieties and to some
degree
it's true in that donald trump as a
faux populist right-wing populist that
rhetoric
certainly appeals to economic anxiety in
many people
but then as we had more information
about the motivations of trump voters
we came to learn that while there was
economic anxiety
on both the left and the right that the
right was motivated to vote for donald
trump by many other things
including the resonance of donald
trump's xenophobia
fear of losing perceived or actual
status
to immigrants coming in and taking jobs
two brown people
s whole countries that entire narrative
and case in point there are so many
counterpoints to the class reductionist
argument
or explanation about last week riots
that
the explanation of this is merely class
struggle
would be dangerous to accept as a full
explanation for what we saw
including by the way that many of the
people
that participated in the insurrection
they had the money to not only
travel to washington dc but to stay in
hotels that aren't cheap now i know that
there were groups funding the travel
but many many for many people that
wasn't the case these people were able
to afford going to dc taking time off
from work
if they have a job if they need to work
and staying in expensive hotels
and so there are uh uh so that's one
aspect
the other aspect is there are tons of
people
on the left and right that economically
are
way worse off than the protesters
rioters last week
but they were not there and there are
even examples of wealthy people
going to dc on private jets to
participate in the riot although that's
anecdotal obviously most of these
rioters
did not fly in on private jets but the
point here
is that there is something unique to
those who yes
mostly are not particularly privileged
economically
but there is a significant xenophobic
component
there is a significant ignorance to
reality component
people who fall for listen if this was
just economic anxiety
you wouldn't see that the people at the
riot are the people who
fell for the obvious lies from trump
about a stolen election
what was really the most common factor
among the rioters
was that they fell for and they believed
that the election was stolen from donald
trump which is demonstrably untrue
there were rich and poor people who fell
for that there were elites and
non-elites who fell for that and
importantly poor people
who didn't fall for it weren't their
rioting people who were significantly
more
economically disadvantaged or oppressed
by the economic system
weren't their rioting because they
didn't believe this stupid narrative
that the election was stolen
and so i very much appreciate the class
aspect
that at a general level has generated
anxiety and a desire for change
the people that participated in this
riot exposed the trump movement for what
it really is
and it's not merely an economic anxiety
movement it's a particularly
extreme radical conspiratorial worldview
informed by being uninformed that sure
to some degree
overlaps with aspects of economic
anxiety but the truth is that at this
point
economic anxiety is a reality for a huge
portion of this country
that there i agree with richard wolff
and others when half the country can't
meet
an unexpected 400 expense without going
into debt
just about any group unless you're
saying we're only serving
private jet owners just about any group
health care workers
factory workers educational workers
whoever all of these groups will include
a lot of economic anxiety but that
doesn't mean that that's the cause
of violent radical insurrectionist
violence
and let's not miss the forest for the
trees and pretend that it goes away
simply by solving economic inequality um
you listen you'll solve economic
inequality
and a lot of these people will be
furious that now
uh they are on the same level as a lot
of people that they don't
deserve they don't believe deserve
believe to be economically stable and
that gets us back to the xenophobia
and and the rest of it so i i think that
these analyses miss the mark i've seen a
bunch of them
and i'm curious to hear your thoughts
you can find me on twitter
at d pacman the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't
thrilled with the idea of going into a
doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays i took their
quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
they have a special offer only for my
audience you'll get 50
off your first month but only until
january 31st so make sure to sign up
soon
click the link right underneath this
video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so there were sadly suspicions
that there may have been police officers
who either stood aside or even helped
the trump rioters on january 6th
and sadly it appears that this is true
we've now learned that
several members of the united states
capitol police have been
suspended according to acting capital
police chief
yogananda pittman earlier yesterday
congressman tim ryan a former guest on
this program
said that two officers had been
suspended one officer took a selfie with
one of the violent insurrectionists
another gave them a tour of the capitol
building
according to congressman ryan tim ryan
also saying that there are 10
to 15 ongoing investigations into
officer conduct during the insurrection
this was at a press conference given
yesterday by tim ryan
ryan also indicated that a third
individual has been arrested but said
it's not
currently clear if they're a member of
the capitol police
or the national guard and this is um
i mean listen there's a few different
things that have to be talked about here
first of all
we were cautious when the theory started
that this was a plot and that capitol
police
in advance were planning to
usher in protesters and i said as those
theories started to
be presented let's be careful about that
because we don't have evidence of that
yet when we saw
you know a 15-second video of police
clearing some barricades and that was
pointed to as evidence of a conspiracy
involving the capitol police i said we
we have to be careful because
anybody who knows about crowd control
knows that once you know
you're you are overwhelmed and your
physical barriers will will not hold
you do move the physical barriers to
avoid others
and yourself getting hurt and trampled
by the barriers themselves and so i
urged caution
and indeed what we know listen i think
one of the important things is
if your view on police is radically
different
today than it was around the george
floyd protests
then you should question whether your
view is tuned to reality
during the george floyd protests my view
was that based on everything i knew
most police officers are doing their
jobs to the best of their abilities
and most police officers are becoming
officers
generally speaking for the right reasons
because they want to
protect their communities uh do do
something that's good for their
communities
and there are a lot there are too many
bad actors
that slip through the cracks due to lack
of systems that prevent them from doing
so and so when you're talking about an
apparatus as large as law enforcement
there's no doubt that there will be
horrible people in a group
uh and a bad apple can spoil the bunch
so it's not a surprise that now we are
starting to see
two three people suspended a dozen under
investigation
i'm sure that there are more than two
officers involved last week
uh and potentially even even uh military
folks as well the investigations are
ongoing
that behaved absolutely atrociously
um eventually there should be firings
and not
suspensions but i think it's also
important
that you know when when we jump into the
conspiracy theories or when we start
making the claims that aren't based in
fact
we become just as bad as them and
there's no reason to do it eventually
the truth is going to
going to come out the suspensions are
happening the arrests of the rioters are
happening and it's all happening and
remember
there are also people in law enforcement
who acted
heroically last week eugene goodman
is a capital police officer who is
rightly being hailed
as a hero who realized what was going on
realized that the armed
that the violent insurrectionist some of
whom we suspect were armed
were getting into the direction of the
senate chamber in which there were
senators
and eugene goodman lured these rioters
in the opposite direction eugene goodman
made himself a decoy
so let's take this a step at a time
yes investigations is anyone surprised
that some
when you look at the percentage of of
law enforcement that voted trump
of course in that there are going to be
some people that are
carried away by what they love to see
there were people in law enforcement who
loved what happened last week some even
participated off duty
so of course we're seeing this so the
investigations must continue
we need attention to be devoted to
investigating supervisors and leadership
to figure out what happened and that
means
both supervisors and leadership who
ignored the signs that were there that
this was likely or probable to happen
um and that needs to be investigated as
well the difficult part
is that for every two that actually
helped in a way
that warrants a suspension like the two
that have been suspended so far
there were a bunch that sort of were
okay with it and kind of looked the
other way
and it wasn't criminally negligent but
it's still very problematic
and that is much more difficult to weed
out and to deal with but again
most of the people on duty were just
doing their jobs and they effectively
ended up abandoned by management and
colleagues
anyone that watches the videos can tell
that a vast majority of the police on
scene
were doing their jobs and they were
putting themselves in harm's way and
very importantly any officer
that was involved in any way must be
fired
they must lose pension progress that
they've made and it must be taken
extraordinarily seriously you're not
going to change political views by doing
this i understand that
uh if you're a trumpist and you get
fired because of your role in the riots
uh trump is police officer you don't all
of a sudden become a progressive i
understand that it would be naive to
think so
but the point is much like the point i
made about the need to
find and arrest and charge and throw the
book at the rioters themselves
which is that and we're going to talk
momentarily about the risk of more of
these riots coming up in the next week
eight days
if the punishments aren't severe they
will be encouraged
to do it again and that's the biggest
risk and it seems that it is sadly going
to happen
so uh i've been talking about this for a
couple of days now and i've been
tweeting about it for some time and i
i tweeted days ago it's unlikely that
january 6th was the last riot or at
least the last attempted riot and indeed
abc has now obtained an fbi bulletin
which is warning all 50 states and
federal law enforcement that
armed protests are being planned at all
50 state capitals it's expected to start
as soon as days from today
and run at least through inauguration
day on january 20th armed protests are
being planned
at all 50 state capitals and in
washington dc
um the uh if you've been following some
of what's been happening on the
right-wing social media platform
parlor you probably also know that at
least the language around going armed
this time
is significantly scarier and more
belligerent
in terms of weapons in dc january 6th
there are anecdotally stories and some
pictures
of what appear to be armed
insurrectionists
although um it it it is not clear that
that was
an overwhelming issue on january 6 and
of course
washington dc gun laws are far stricter
than the gun laws in many of the states
from which the insurrectionists came on
parlor
increasingly the language about going
armed to the next series of riots
is significantly more belligerent and to
the extent that some of these riots
rather than being in washington dc
are going to be at state capitals uh it
is likely
that many of these would be
insurrectionists
and will not only be armed at the future
protest but they will be armed legally
okay the fbi has also received
information
about a group that is calling for
storming
courthouses as well as administrative
buildings
if donald trump is removed from office
anytime prior
to inauguration day or if trump is
impeached by the house of
representatives
or storming once joe biden is sworn in
which he will be on january 20th
regardless of what else happens between
now and then so there's there's a few
thoughts about this number one the
reality is
that this isn't we will do this only if
trump is impeached
or only if trump is removed by the 25th
amendment
the reality is that the the the
likelihood of this happening again is
under any circumstance in which joe
biden becomes president so
when i hear members of the republican
party saying we have to heal and move on
impeachment would be divisive it's time
to go trump reduced the
the temperature with his ridiculous one
minute video last week or whatever
um they number one are clearly
downplaying the current threat
level but most importantly it doesn't
matter what the house or senate do
the terrorists supporting the q anon
garbage aren't going to change their
minds they're not going to stop
if and when joe biden becomes president
and he's going to
it is likely that we are going to see
more of this and that's horrifying the
only way that these people
don't do it is if somehow trump is
allowed to remain
president that's the only condition that
they will accept which is of course
unacceptable to society
it's incongruent with the law and it
can't be allowed to happen so
that's the reality there will be
right-wing violence if joe biden is
sworn in
there will be right-wing violence if
donald trump is impeached there will be
right-wing violence if donald trump is
removed via the 25th amendment
there will be right-wing violence if
trump resigns because he will have been
forced
to resign is the way that they will see
it so
unfortunately if there's going to be
violence there's going to be violence
merely because donald trump didn't get
another four years
they're not rational they've tied their
identity to donald trump and trump is
leaving
and they're angry they are irrational
many of them feel lost they're not
interested in governance or policy or
the rule of law
and they've gone over the line and
turned to violence instead of respecting
our institutions
that that's it that's the full story now
we can pull in
how much of it is economic anxiety how
much of it is racism how much is
xenophobia how much of it is cognitive
dissonance or ignorance what role does
mental illness or in-cell culture play
great but a line has been crossed
where any scenario in which donald trump
doesn't get another four years
to some portion of these people warrants
violence and that's why the fbi is now
uh worried about what looks to be likely
over the next week so let's all be safe
let's all be careful
um and we're going to continue following
all of this as well as
what will the house of representatives
and senate do and mike pence potentially
about donald trump
uh i believe he will be president all
the way to january 20th at noon
uh we will have more of about this on
our instagram page find us on instagram
at david pakman show
and you can also find me on instagram
david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show
today i'm going to be speaking
with filmmaker and journalist daniel
lombroso whose debut feature
white noise is based on his four years
reporting inside the alt-right
and uh opened last year daniel so great
to talk to you today
thank you for having me on the show so
in the film
you uh spend time with at least
some folks that i know to some degree
i've interviewed
richard spencer a few years ago and it
was sort of a
interesting experience which which we
can talk about i mean i guess first to
kind of set the stage
what was the goal here how did you get
into covering the alt-right and and how
did you end up
um basically meeting a lot of these
people and spending time with them
so i was one of the first reporters in
the country to start covering the
alt-right right around when actually you
were putting out these really important
primers on the movement and i was
watching them at the time
if you go back to 2016 when trump was a
candidate the movement was not getting a
lot of attention and i was a young
reporter at the atlantic at the time
and you know i just said to my editors
like there's this fiercely anti-semitic
racist movement that's bubbling up
online at the time on reddit and
obviously 4chan as well
i had only graduated from college a few
years earlier so i saw you know
aspects of that on college campuses
already and i just said to the editors
of the atlantic this is something we
have to pay attention to it's only
growing in strength
um a few months later i i started
covering richard spencer before he was a
household name
and i was the one who actually caught a
room full of people breaking out into
nazi salutes you might remember that
viral video at the time yep
and that was really important because it
clarified that
this wasn't just a group of edgy
conservatives like the way it was
covered
and i think you also did a great job of
clarifying that at the time
this was fundamentally a white
nationalist movement and it needed to be
covered
you know with the utmost due diligence
and care
when charlottesville happened about
eight months later the atlantic
understood that this was only growing in
strength and they gave me the space to
to produce a feature film so that's when
it really became a full-time project
when you look at uh your time
spent with these folks and i know i know
you've covered richard spencer you've
covered mike cernovich you've covered
lauren southern
and and many others um there i'm curious
your
thoughts on whether we can make any more
general assessments of the goals of
these folks because
to some degree i feel like many of them
recognize that their goals at least as
stated are not likely to become a
reality anytime
soon and so that leads me to wonder
about
whether this is essentially a marketing
of some kind marketing themselves pr
a sense essentially becoming known
within a movement and less less about
actually achieving the movement's goals
or whether or whatever i mean i guess
that's that's
i'll leave it there it's a great
question
i mean it really runs the gamut i think
fundamentally this is a violent movement
richard spencer who coined the term
alt-right
he believes in a white ethno state what
that might sound like a flashy word but
what it means is a country that has
let's say 90
white population the us is 63
white and declining every year i think
that's great we should live
not that we cheer for that but it's
great to have a multicultural country
where everyone gets along
you know to get to the 90 white
ethnostate we're talking about mass
deportations we're talking about ethnic
cleansing
those are fundamentally racist ideas but
then you get the other side of it and
white noise really is all about the
spectrum of the alt-right and how it
goes all the grifterism that's part of
it
you get a guy like mike cernovich who
you know is happy to benefit from the
racism and how it can help you build a
brand
and you see over the course of the film
that he's selling skincare products he's
selling pills
he's making money off of big parties and
like some
crappy bar in new york city there's
there's so much about it that's
opportunism it's celebrity it's vanity
so the motivations are mixed and i think
that's why people are having a lot of
having trouble sometimes making sense of
what happened wednesday they're saying
is this serious or is it larping
it can be both and i found that it was
both yeah i mean it seems like in a
country of 331 million
uh there's plenty of room for all of the
above to be
examples of it and to still have plenty
of everything
exactly and i think what needs to be
clear though is that even if you're
coming from it
as someone who's larping who's
cosplaying who's having their moment in
the sun
you're still adjacenting yourself to the
spencers to the oath keepers to these
people who
believe this is a white man's country
and i think that's
you know morally problematic and maybe
that will get you some more twitter
followers and some money but
it's not worth the coalition that you're
in one of the things that's come up in
the days since the january 6th
uh riotous insurrection um is
uh some even people i i respect like for
example economist richard wolff who was
my college professor
and others have been sort of reducing
what took place last week to
economic oppression and the the natural
result of inequality
and i respect a lot of the folks that
are saying this but i think that these
are
are sort of some of their less good
takes and i did a commentary about it
earlier on in today's program i'm
curious because
you you were in and observing a lot of
these
movements uh what what can we say about
the degree to which
economic oppression plays a role not for
people like spencer who i believe is
from a wealthy family individually but
in the people that follow these
movements
to what degree like could it be that
economic oppression
is what makes them liable to get sucked
in but is not really the focus of the
activism or what can we say about the
economic aspect
i think the economic anxiety argument is
nonsense no offense to to the professor
i mean most of the people that i covered
were from upper middle class
highly educated they live in new york dc
los angeles
all the scenes in my film take place in
liberal enclaves san francisco
you know southern california dc many
others i mean that's where these
movements have strength and of course
they can't they attract foot soldiers
from
alabama and whatever but this is not
like your granddaddy's
racism of people in you know in trailer
parks like burning crosses and of course
there's some of that iconography
but this is the leaders down to the
followers are really like
smart educated kids um you know who've
been
radicalized by these ideas and you ask
about how it happens it's not because
they're hit with high taxes and they
feel like it's it's tyrannical and they
just want a more libertarian state maybe
there are a few of those people i met
very few of them
what it really is is that these people
are selling you on a promise that
you might be a bored unemployed kid in
your mom's basement
but you're actually a descendant of a
crusader of a greek of a roman
that you could take part in this amazing
historical legacy
um and i think that's a really
intoxicating narrative to see that
you're not just
you know a dis you know a disaffected
kid with no sense of purpose in the
world you could take part in something
larger
and that's what they're really appealing
to is this sense of narrative kind of
this sense of purpose
existential purpose well when i've when
i've interviewed former kkk neo-nazi
types uh you know frank mink
and scott shepherd and you know a lot of
these different interesting people
and those who have spent time with them
folks like daryl davis as an example
the thing that invariably comes up is
that they were pulled
into these movements from a very
particular circumstance which
almost always is lack of connection to
other people
often parents but not necessarily
feeling
out of touch with anything that they
would call community
sometimes there's abuse psychological or
physical that's going on
and and for the most part they will they
will recognize
these are the ones that made it out
right so it's a self-selected group but
they will recognize that the ideology
could have almost been anything
from whoever kind of presented them with
empathy and connection and a place where
they could belong
can you talk about that a little bit in
the experiences you've had
researching and doing the film it's a
great point i mean when you're inside
the movement it feels like a subculture
that could be any kind of subculture
it's almost like they're internet
celebrities who happen to be racist and
of course
the racism is important but what you
notice immediately is the is
the commonalities the code of
communication they all dress the same
you know 20th century like hitler youth
style haircuts
many of richard spencer's followers wear
short shorts and they're all drinking
the same drinks like whiskey they're all
eating the same foods
there's all of these in-group jokes i
mean it's really a community it's a cult
like any
other and it i've done a lot of embedded
reporting and other types of
fundamentalist movements but any any
sort of community
and it resembles any sort of tight-knit
community where the community
is conferring importance onto the
followers giving them a sense of purpose
in the world
and i think if you track it to the
individual
all of them have a sense of resentment
they feel like they haven't been given
their due in the world so
mike cernovich was an out-of-work lawyer
his first wife
was very successful she's like she's a
lawyer at several
big tech companies and they got divorced
he took a lot of her money and
he took a lot of money in alimony which
is very you know beta for the so-called
alpha male
um and he felt really resentful that he
never really took off as a lawyer
and then he found a niche in this world
he became someone prestigious on the far
right
um you know mainstreaming everything
from pizzagate to that hillary had
parkinson's
he became a person of status and i think
that's what this can provide and
and the list goes on and on richard
spencer was an out-of-work journalist
never got any attention and then one day
trump ran was the gasoline that spencer
needed to start the engine and
all of them especially the leadership
share that kind of story where
the movement gave them i gave them a
purpose in the world
not that this was the most important
thing you just said but it just kind of
peaked my curiosity you say
they eat the same foods what foods are
they eating that that's that's
interesting
um you know there's there's a few funny
examples uh
lauren southern who's one of the three
characters in the film and i think
probably the most interesting
her her boyfriend at the time they've
now broken up
we joked with a culinary white
supremacist because he told me he
refused to eat
quote non-european foods really so i
went
i i filmed them on a date once and he
wouldn't touch the ketchup because he
claimed ketchup
was originally derived from china from
the word ketz up or something
so he wouldn't touch the ketchup and we
ate it like a british pub in toronto
they ate um it's in the film and it's
also in an article i wrote about lauren
and that
section of the story went totally viral
on twitter because it's just absurd
yeah that's interesting like i wonder is
is brisket considered
white russian or jewish like would
brisket be acceptable
i wonder where they would come down on
that well jews are not part of the ethno
state
right i i'm jewish and i was on a road
trip with
with spencer to one of his shoots and
the car broke down once and we were
stuck in central florida and pitch black
at a gas station for a few hours
and i said richard like can i be a part
of your ethno state
and he was like i'm sorry daniel but uh
it's not going to work
it's interesting you mentioned that
because when i had them on there was
this question of sort of like
you know the a lot of this idea of the
ethnostate is based on some fundamental
incompatibility
of these groups that just that like we
can kind of pretend to get along and he
said you and i could probably get
together and have a beer
and there would not be an obvious
conflict in that particular interaction
but at some bigger picture level there's
differences in values there's
differences in culture etc
uh and and i don't know if he this
interview was three and a half years ago
i don't know if it's he or others
in of azil who have said that when jews
appear to be integrated into american
culture
it's because they've essentially given
up
whatever is core to them and are kind of
adopting
the american thing there's kind of these
post hoc explanations but
you actually did the thing like you hung
around for a while
yeah and i think what happens i'm also
you know i'm jewish i'm also the
grandson of two holocaust survivors and
over time i would tell my subjects about
their terrible stories you know losing
most of their families
you know i think everyone makes
exceptions for people they like and the
honest truth is that they came to like
me they would text me and
vulnerable moments a lot of that you
know that stuff that was on the record
is in the story i wrote about lauren
you know they would make exceptions but
the truth is is that like the jew
is and always has been a stand-in for
any sort of issue that we see in society
so now they're
the bankers that you know soros
obviously is something we use all the
time he's the image of the parasite
who's
pulling the strings from behind the
scenes you know it's very common to hear
them talk about the rothschilds use
to talk about the zionist occupied
government which really isn't anything
about israel it's actually saying
that the u.s is occupied by jews behind
the scenes
and you know i think there's so much dog
whistle anti-semitism that's all around
in this movement
some of them don't even realize that
they're purveying it and others are
actively doing it and when it comes to
the ethnic state you know
they're very very clear that that this
might come as a surprise to most
americans but that jews don't count as
white
in far-right contexts historically and
europe jews were not considered white
they were the original other
of course and um yeah and and you know
richard to achieve his dream is willing
to accept any kind of
white person that wouldn't have
historically been seen white just
because he needs numbers so
he'll take russians he'll take southern
italians all the undesirables of the
past are fine
right but jews because of their unique
history would would not be part of it
in the limited time we have left based
on you all of your work and and
knowledge and experience
we're wondering once trump goes a lot of
these folks that seem to have only
gotten involved
in politics because of trump and don't
really care about policy they're not
really conservatives in the traditional
sense
do they remain engaged do they mostly go
back to being apolitical the way they
were before trump
i think they remain engaged and the
reason is this there's a huge
market opportunity for these ideas there
are millions of people who believe them
stop this deal the hashtag around you
know that the
election was elite you know supposedly
stolen from trump it's completely untrue
people are bringing hundreds of
thousands or even millions of dollars
behind that fraudulent idea
there are many individuals i'm not going
to call them out by name who've made a
lot of money from that
that lie and many other lies the market
opportunity will remain because there
are millions of resentful people
that believe that this is a white man's
country and believe that president trump
was wrongfully terminated by a bunch of
liberals and jews and democrats and as
long as you know there is a base that's
willing to eat up and pay for those
ideas
the individuals will still be there
ready to hawk them and make money off
them
all right uh we've been speaking with
daniel lombroso the film is white
noise what are all the places where
people can find the film daniel
it's on amazon prime it's also on itunes
and we're doing a global educational
tour so if you're interested in
having a dialogue around the film you
can reach out to me as well thanks
daniel i really appreciate you telling
us about it today
thanks so much for having me that was
great the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world-famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's join
pakman.com if the normal prices
strike you as high by all means use the
coupon code
vote soon18 all one word all lowercase
become a member today
david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so there's a new propaganda war being
waged right now that was triggered by
donald trump's suspension from twitter
and is growing because of the distancing
that many for-profit businesses have
decided they want to make from the
right-wing social media app
parlor and i have news for everybody
who's furious
about what's happening to parlor woke
mobs are not destroying parlor
regulation is not destroying parlor the
government is not destroying parlor
hackers are not destroying parlor
capitalism is solely to blame for what
is happening to parlor
capitalism is responsible for parlor's
demise
apple and amazon have removed parlor
from their services
because as for-profit companies they can
do whatever the hell they want partially
because republicans have refused to
regulate them they are making business
decisions
that they determined are best for them
and they are making these
decisions within a free market in which
you and i as consumers can also decide
wow
i don't like what apple did to parlor so
now i'm going to boycott apple
or i can decide you know what i like
what apple did to parlor
i'm going to go and buy 10 iphones if i
want to do that
google decided to remove parlor from
their app store
because they say parlor isn't
sufficiently policing user posts and so
a whole bunch of posts that encourage
and incite violence and crime
are remaining on the platform and there
are people who
are furious and saying well hold on a
second google is kind of a monopoly so
how can you say
well if they're not on google uh on
on the google play app store then you
can get parlor
because google has a lot of market power
well
where were these exact same republicans
when
elizabeth warren was saying we've got to
deal with the monopoly power of these
companies they were against it these
same republicans who now are saying
but but but they have monopoly power
they were against dealing with monopoly
power when we on the left
were sounding the alarm about the lack
of antitrust enforcement
which was allowing monopoly power to
grow
unchecked in the united states so
there's a real irony
in that unregulated capitalism and the
legalization of pseudo-monopolies are
responsible for the downfall
of this far-right social media platform
because the party
that has been asking for more capitalism
and more corporate freedom
got it and now they're furious that they
have that freedom
and it has led to a free market of ideas
and decisions
in which many companies decided we don't
want anything to do with parlor
nobody's preventing the people at parlor
from hosting their own servers and
paying for them that's how capitalism
works and
much like fox news is now being
destroyed by the monster
they created now that fox news is not
quite radical enough
for some people fox news is losing some
of their own radical audience to newsmax
and oan
that's the same mechanism that's at play
here the only question i have
is whether the right is pretending not
to understand this or if they genuinely
don't understand that
this is a circumstance of their own
making no one's first amendment rights
have been silenced here everyone can say
whatever the hell they want but there
are for-profit companies
saying we don't want anything to do with
what parlor is offering
amazon isn't required to provide hosting
services to parlor
when parlor allows members to violate
the terms and conditions for amazon
hosting
amazon will lose money because they lose
parlor as a client
but that's amazon's call to make and by
the way let's go even further
anti-masters
by the way being removed from places of
business by business owners that's not
government regulation
that's a company deciding what's best
for us
is not to have anti-massacres here
that's something they're allowed to do
dc rioters being put on no-fly lists
because airlines have decided they don't
want their business
or corporations saying you were at the
dc riots
you're fired we don't want you working
for us that's the free market
and lots of the people crying about free
speech
first of all don't understand what it
means and secondly
think that free speech means freedom
from consequences
to your speech the consequences to your
speech
in the free market are part of free
speech
the speech and the consequences are all
part of speech
and remember that when we want to talk
about the first amendment we have to be
talking about
the government which is yet another
detail that seems to be missed here now
you are going to hear and in fact we're
going to talk about it in the next
segment
you are going to hear that all of these
companies are limiting the first
amendment rights of individuals
that these companies are engaged in
censorship
or whatever the case may be go back and
check out the interview
i did with a first amendment
legal scholar about the
misunderstandings that people have about
what that even means i know many of you
know it but in case many of you don't
check that out
and let's now discuss us continued
misunderstanding deliberate or not
um on the tucker carlson program so one
of the most
interesting micro stories or sort of
like sub stories of the entire trump
being banned from twitter
and parlor being kicked off at the apple
store is the story of republican senator
josh hawley's book
so i'm going to kind of catch everybody
up quickly if we're not all on the same
page the story won't make a lot of sense
so the meat of the story is as follows
republican senator josh hawley got a lot
of attention
before january 6th and he got an atta
boy from donald trump
because josh hawley was the first
republican senator
to say he would be objecting to the
electoral vote count on january 6th
there had been a number of members of
the house of representatives who had
said
we will object i will object but for the
objections to actually stop the count
and lead to the two hours of debate that
normally would would take place
you also need a senator to object and
josh hawley
was the first senator to say i will be
objecting
cut to january 6th and we have a violent
insurrection
led by trumpists and after they were
able to re-secure
the capitol building later on january
6th and they reconvened
josh hawley kept going with his
objections and his bogus arguments about
the election
so as a result of that josh hawley lost
a business opportunity
book publisher simon schuster decided
they don't want to have anything to do
with josh hawley anymore and they said
we are backing out of the book deal that
we had made with josh hawley now
remember simon
schuster is a company that exists in the
united states
meaning they get to decide who they work
with they get to decide what book they
publish it's not the government
if the government got to decide what
book simon and schuster published
we would be more like a country with
centralized control of industry some
might call them communist countries we
would not be
what we are if anybody were able to tell
simon and schuster you must publish josh
hawley's book
well josh hawley went on tucker
carlson's program last night
and they both seem to not understand how
capitalism works all of a sudden let's
get into it
senator thanks so much for coming on so
there you're now one of the most
despised uh
people in america so i appreciate you
taking the time for being hated to come
on the show tonight
but i want to ask you specifically about
what happened between you and simon and
schuster and i should say i published
with simon schuster i have a book
contract for a
future book was simon schuster it's
making me very uncomfortable watching
what they did
to you um what ground did they cancel
your book contract
so let's even stop there just for a
moment tucker says now
he himself is uncomfortable because he
has an upcoming book deal with simon
schuster well you know what tucker
you can act on that you can deal with
that if you're uncomfortable with what
simon and schuster did
you have the power to say to simon and
schuster i don't want to do the book
with you anymore
i'm going to find some right wing
publisher or whatever the case may be
that's how capitalism works if tucker
decides i'd rather not work with simon
schuster i'd rather not accept the money
he can say to them i'm out
let's continue well they don't like the
exercise of free speech tucker i think
is at the end of the day i mean this is
really about the first amendment it's
really about free speech
and simon and schuster that didn't like
me doing what democrats in congress did
in 2001
and 2005 and 2017 when democrat members
of congress
objected during the certification
process in order to try to have a debate
about election integrity you know that's
the first amendment at work that's
democracy at work but
simon and schuster unfortunately a lot
of people on the left now decided that
the first amendment is something that
they no longer support and i'll just say
this tucker
at a time of division we've got to rally
around the things that
unites us as americans and i think the
first amendment of free speech
has got to be at the top of that list so
this is not about the first amendment
why why do they keep talking about the
first amendment josh hawley has a right
as a lawmaker it's not really even about
speech
as a senator josh hawley can object to
votes
on the grounds he objected to them simon
and schuster as a corporation
that exists in the united states can
decide we want to publish a book with
josh hawley or we don't that's it
that's the full story here josh hawley
is wrong that this is about the first
amendment or about free speech
and he also either forgets or doesn't
know or pretends not to know
that even if it were a free speech issue
freedom of speech doesn't mean
freedom from the consequences of that
speech speech has consequences it's
called
capitalism which they support tucker
then also appears not to get it
so if some polis some creepy low iq
politician says i want to shut down the
other side okay
i get it but a publisher is literally
the guardian of the first amendment
if you're a publisher you exist because
of the first amendment your duty is to
protect
the first amendment but the people
around simon and schuster are now so
crazed with ideology
that they can't bear to hear a contrary
view expressed i mean what what does
that
pretend for the country well i think it
really shows sucker that we're in a
period where the first amendment
values and principles of freedom of
speech also freedom of worship freedom
of religion
these things are are really under attack
by some quarters by many quarters
that is not at all what this is about
this has nothing to do with
simon schuster wanting to suppress
speech or not being willing to hear
a different opinion simon schuster made
a business decision
josh hawley is a disgusting depraved
extremist
agitator his actions on january 6th
confirm it
simon and schuster decided you know the
the books we would sell
by doing this book with josh hawley for
us
don't outweigh the downside to our
business
of working with him and they made a
decision how can anyone argue against
simon and schuster's unilateral right to
make that decision
now if simon and schuster said we refuse
to publish books by or employ
black people whoa hold on a second now
we're violating non-discrimination laws
that would be a very different story but
simon and shuster simply said we
we don't want to do business with
someone and holly goes
to the first amendment here take a look
and again i come back
to the fact that this is something the
first amendment is something that unites
us
as americans and in this time of
division in this time of chaos
we've got to we've got to stand strong
for that if you're wondering why
when reporters go to trump rallies and
they interview people
the people start talking about this is a
first amendment violation and that's a
first amendment violation and this
violated my free speech or trump's free
speech
this is why they are bombarded
constantly with people
who either don't understand or are
deliberately lying to them
about what is a free speech issue what
is
a first first amendment issue when it
has nothing to do
with that whatsoever so you know i
every time i ask this a bunch of people
say tucker definitely knows this is not
really about speech
josh hawley probably also knows they're
being disingenuous
that maybe that may be it doesn't matter
why they're doing it
it's bamboozling a lot of people and
again it goes back to education and
media literacy
if more people were better educated they
wouldn't fall for this nonsense about
this being an issue of speech let me
know what you think
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
uh i'm getting more and more emails
voicemails
tweets as my goatee has filled in
still pathetically but it has there are
lots of people who are not pleased with
it take a listen to this
okay david pakman yes
thomas from austin calling
sounding the alarm yeah
we don't need to go into this
kind of goatee phase that i
see happening yeah i'm very
happy about your vitamin d levels thank
you
but the goatee
it's not gonna work man you've gotta go
clean shaven looking good
like a news man yeah so listen i am not
a newsman
i am merely an analyst a commentator
so there's no editor telling me i need
to be clean-shaven but it's not going to
last that much longer
my girlfriend has already put in her
complaint about it
um and it's not going i think i will
probably do one show with just the
handlebar mustache and then it'll be
gone
i know this is not very important but in
a time when so much is happening that is
extraordinarily disturbing
uh why not talk about one more
disturbing thing which is my
inability to grow serious facial hair
we've got a great bonus show for you
today
i am so glad to see that new england
patriots coach bill belichick
is uh not going to be moving forward
with receiving the presidential medal of
freedom from donald trump
very glad to see it we will talk about
that and much more on the bonus show
grab a membership at jointpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
steady md lets you maintain a meaningful
long-lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman